got them near my house he's on the river
this is a big ass bitch
this mother spiked me do a little bit of
crabbing out here today and we're not
talking about the ones that hit your
ball Bob as a mother thing that's gonna
let you know when the fish has
protectors now what I like to do is I
like to take the sand strip from behind
and stick that thing right in his
asshole
I'm thinking it's the end of I was
scared to pick the book good you look
like a big-ass dinosaur s-sure keep like
he's a five pet don't want to go with
you I want to go in jail right here is
on the boat y'all standing on the dock
even fishing shows are watchable when
you add cool black people we'd see
crappie killin west red diamond they
host a web series called you all read
the title they use the term that only
black people Tarantino and Bill Maher
allowed to say and by they I mean these
two and not they and any other way as
one be clear they're just like white
fishermen except their worms are longer
and they never get those stupid
sunglasses and line fishing is the only
horrible blue-collar job that people
willingly take up as a hobby is the best
way to avoid women but still reek of
rotten vagina girls don't fish because
it's physically impossible for them to
shut up for 30 minutes
sexist drink my favorite secret fishing
spot is the seafood counter whole food
ask for Dudley I don't get the appeal of
fishing who wants a float in a boat all
day like a refugee
unless this bunch of naked bitches on
the bow I'm out but if those anglers are
trying to break down the color barrier
in the world's most boring sport behind
NASCAR bowling and foosball I'll bring
them to hollywood for this week's
celebrity profile
[Applause]
[Music]
what we're going to rebel I'm your host
cropping killer and this is wet red
diamond today we are fishing in a
disgusting polluted pond in a Culver
City little special yes Daniel Tosh
ain't you know any fun thing they do
like cracker on the creek can't be on
the harder oh wow I could not see yeah I
could not see them good hey is it cool
just while we're on the river if you let
me use the n-word say it and find out
that sounds like a test I don't think
I'm gonna do it hey you want some fish
sticks
no no these are guitar so these are
delicious
here's related yeah your brother's yes
why did you come up with west branch and
crappie killer what his names mean the
web Brad means like bread in the West
right no I'm a rapper music so we just
like that was something that I just
typically ran with what he'd been
dropping killer since he's been killing
100 mm but a little small pan fish
that's what a crappie look like I was
just known for killing moms - baby
sister brothers grandma grandpa
Rita called the whole tribe does that
get you as much cred killing little
copies that's about how many you can
catch okay so you're from Portland yeah
you like it up there it's wet but it's
good I know but so many uh drug addicts
up there right you got to come up here
and see for yourself
all right so how long you had this show
of yours this channel over a year we
started in
Homer who came up with the title they
came up with the title
inappropriate it wasn't in a panel just
a strong I hear you just so hard to say
it I just look around like this rapper
Tupac came up with nothing he did never
ignorant getting goes accomplished and
it came because we was like actually
starting to get like profile every time
we went out there was like one like
standing on a black and confidence' so
first of all you're in Portland you know
on a river there's nothing any black
things were there anyone right I mean
except for the Trailblazers that's it
you know who the original ener-d are is
the guy from Huck Finn and more Jim
maybe and make us read that in school
you because that was something I was mad
at it's not the ni GGA no one is always
the Nikkei okay they wanted you to know
he was oh no we don't know that Jim do
you feel that you like fish as much
or no not a black people that's it of
course they might get harassed a little
bit more but we get harassed by the game
war game warned police it is a hassle
you about the weed at all so with a good
or going in three for the blood which
you can do while you operate machinery
had nothing but I mean as long you
smoking before and after than a okay but
you guys are smoking during let's be
honest no it's medicine sure is your
Moby Dick even bigger mo Gd oh no well
you know I had no complaints what about
those good ol boys at Bass Pro Shop they
nice to you they all love us
I mean B I'ma be honest though before
the show it was more so like hey like
that's why we came up with the name like
business like you know there's that's
how we felt we got out there was like I
don't wanna say it anyway now they just
pull up and be like what I thought and
then maybe one to said maybe like edit
the guys look it it's the rebel zoom
you guys ever bring token white friends
with you fishing always we always have a
lot of random white friends you guys now
can really relate to what Tiger Woods
went through oh man and you having to
hang out with all these white people no
not that far I hear you but I'm just
saying try to dance too because even
getting a whole lot of pussies like
these what brought them down yeah yeah
we're trying to catch fishes not bitches
what do you think of those meth-head
that are on the deadliest catch is are
you there okay I'm dressed like he was
on the deadliest catch ride me
I was working son yeah any fish that you
guys do don't put it all now we put
every battle chang'an today he's
allergic to so what are you doing his
snoot in your cell would you just give
it to him while I eat it kind of cleared
God makes you such a great fisherman
allergic to fish at one point I can eat
them
it used to be he couldn't eat the salmon
we were kids he kids I shouldn't eat
shellfish and certain fish at all when
all the kids and I got older and out of
it you guys want them like peed together
in a magic and rich personality they did
plenty of crisscross is when we were
little I could not even smoke to the
fish be in the river
the local moto and locally yeah I smell
some reefer you got our nose don't you
this doesn't look like an approved PFD
drop the cut that's a fishing pole yeah
come on man it's all phosphate to one $1
but drop the weapon in the water now
you fellas got your fishing permit yeah
we got our patient partner I did not
apply for one don't worry about it sir
you're in shock bad news boys fishing
without a license is a serious crime
just rip them up stop resisting
I'm gonna need you to step outside the
boat step into what the water sir okay
we'll have them off the boat in no time
it's like press charges I just want this
whole ugly incident efendi
[Music]
I'd like to thank Daymond John for
giving me that FUBU fish and slicker as
a slicker not slicker
[Music]
[Applause]
you